welcome back to CBS mornings we're
looking at the big issues for voters in
the midterms including access to
abortion a new study by an abortion
rights advocacy Group found that
abortions declined by six percent
Nationwide in the months after Roe v
Wade was overturned but the number of
procedures has gone up in the states
where abortion is legal especially in
places like Illinois which border states
with more restrictions Adriana Diaz
traveled to the southern part of that
state home to a new mobile plan
Parenthood Clinic complete with two exam
rooms a waiting area and a lab her
report is the CBS morning's broadcast
exclusive
this may look like your standard
long-haul RV but step on board and it's
a fully operational medical facility
or as these Planned Parenthood employees
call it an act of activism it looks very
much like a regular brick and mortar
Health Center for us but you can like
feel the fact that we're not on yes
we're not in a building it is a little
more bouncy Dr Colleen mcnicholas is the
chief medical officer at Planned
Parenthood of St Louis she says the
mobile clinic will be parked in Illinois
near the border with Missouri to make
abortions easier to access from out of
state they plan to provide medical
abortions by pill here in the mobile
unit by the end of the year and surgical
procedures next year
it's part of planned parenthood's answer
to the Supreme Court overturning Roe
versus Wade in June since then they've
seen a 370 percent increase at their
southern Illinois Clinic from patients
traveling from Beyond Illinois and
Missouri was the influx what you
anticipated we saw it a lot more quickly
than we expected it to come it came fast
and furious it came fast and furious we
are in Illinois where abortion is legal
but is providing abortion to women in
Missouri where it is illegal
undermining Missouri law
you know our priority is making sure
that the constituents who have been left
behind in those states have access to
basic health care
Missouri only had one abortion clinic
left before Roe fell due in part to
lobbyists like Sam Lee of campaign life
Missouri an anti-abortion Rights group
we think it's very irresponsible for
Planned Parenthood trying to solicit
Missouri women and then when a woman has
a complication where can she go back to
to get help when that abortion van is
gone instead Lee wants to see more
resources go to alternatives for
pregnant women here in Missouri like
pregnancy centers and housing help it
always comes down to for women who are
unsure about their decision or are being
coerced into their decision being given
true choices
with so many raw emotions being
expressed on both sides of this issue we
were really thoughtful about the
security and safety of the unit the RV
is equipped with cameras and will
initially have a security guard still Dr
mcnicholas says this is the time to push
boundaries we're really at a critical
moment a Public Health crisis where we
need folks to be thinking differently to
be working together
to be acting boldly and to be taking
risks for CBS mornings I'm Adriana Diaz
in Southern Illinois